I'm gonna start with I'm very sorry to
anybody who's taken offense to anybody
who's to anybody who's who I've hurt who
I have hurt doja cats it's the Instagram
live Monday morning in a lengthy video
addressing the claims made against her
that sparked the hashtag dosha cat is
over party on Twitter so I'm just gonna
1 debunk everything I have bullet points
here the hashtag emerged after the
rapper was accused of participating and
erases video chats
she was also caught out for a song she
wrote in 2015 titled didn't do nothing
which is a racist slur mocking victims
of police brutality that song is in zero
ways in no way connected to police
brutality or Sandra bland and to see
something like that to see a song my
song that I made connected to an
innocent black woman's death is one of
the most awful rumors that I've ever
encountered
the 24 year old went on to give her
explanation behind the song the term
that I used in the song is one that I
learned that day so people were calling
me at left and right left and right and
I used it in a song and it was to kind
of take back and I can just say to you
to those people the song however I agree
the worst maybe the worst song in the
entire world
the sex doll rapper also addressed
accusations that she participated in a
white supremacist chatroom I learned you
know that there are racist people who
come in and out of the chat there
they're there they
they happen and then they're banned the
I the idea that this chatroom is a white
supremacist chatroom is I don't fully I
don't understand it in any way late
Sunday night those you posted a written
statement on social media addressing the
chatroom videos that have surfaced as
well as the song during her live video
she had this to say about that apology
the apology that I posted is absolutely
an edited piece from me and the people I
work with like any business like any
conglomerate there would be many people
trying to protect what's going on
the singer played snippets of all of the
apologies she compiled before deciding
to go live I understand one thing when I
get hey guys what's up guys
admitting to filming 98 videos in total
there is no better apology than me doing
what I've always done being on live
telling you guys my truth and being
completely honest it's a hard time right
now but recording myself apologizing and
recording myself sounding perfectly
diplomatic as the big and lie I can make
to you
dosha end at the 30 minute video with
this message to her fans I really am so
so so grateful and there's no word for
for me to describe how much I love you
guys and I really do I I'm so sorry if I
hurt you guys and disappointed and
offended anybody on Twitter Instagram
if you're a true fan of me if you're
young all of my young fans you know
people who look up to me you know my
behavior isn't something that always
needs to be followed I'm not perfect
and but then at the end of the day I
shouldn't be doing dumb [ __ ] but also I
need to stand up for myself
[Music]